these are pictures of people who have
arrived late to their exam and have been
locked out they might have only been a
few minutes late but this is brazil's
national high school exam
enem
and at the same time all across the
country the exam starts and the gates
are locked and by the looks of this if
you're not there on time they're really
not letting you in
this footage is heartbreaking because
the exam is so important it only takes
place once per year and it is used for
entry into many of the brazilian
universities in 2016 there are 8.6
million candidates which makes it the
second largest exam in the world behind
china's gao cow it doesn't come without
controversy this year the exam took
place despite the pandemic causing
extensive school closures and hardships
for many students in fact this year
about 50 of registered candidates failed
to show up and only a month ago 37
workers resigned from the agency that
prepares the exam amidst claims of
political censorship of some of the
questions
thank you to everyone who requested i
take a look at this exam some have even
been waiting two years for me to get
around to it one person said they
thought it was harder than the sat but
easier than exams in asian countries and
i do tend to agree with that at least
the countries that i've looked at in
previous videos i've got a copy of the
2021 exam here to take a look at in
total there are 180 questions taken over
two days lasting a total of ten and a
half hours which is huge
it covers languages social science
natural science and mathematics
i've got here the natural science and
math paper
for this there are 45 questions on the
sciences that's chemistry physics and
biology and then another 45 questions
for math for this paper you would have
five hours so that works out to just
over three minutes per question the
questions are all multi-choice but if
you take a look at them they're
extremely wordy and very long and sort
of set up now this is all in portuguese
but i've also run the exam through a
translator and here is the english
version some things have been lost in
translation but i think it gives a
pretty good idea of what the exam is
about you might also notice that some of
the questions are pretty visual this one
here is from the pretty famous comic
calvin and hobbes and it looks like the
boy is complaining that it's hot but the
tiger says that what really bothers them
is the humidity
the question then asks why that might be
the case
with the answer being that sweat has
greater difficulty in evaporating from
the body when it's humid let's have a go
at question 115. again there's a really
long lead up to even know what the
question is about but it says that in
autumn the leaves of trees change color
from green to shades of yellow brown
orange and red the green color of the
leaves is due to the pigment chlorophyll
in plants with deciduous leaves the
production of chlorophyll decreases and
the green tone fades allowing other
pigments such as carotene with a yellow
orange coloration
and anthocyanin with a reddish tone to
dominate the tones of the leaves the
observed coloration is due to the
interaction of these pigments with solar
radiation as shown in the absorption
spectrum the chlorophyll molecules
absorb solar radiation in the blue and
red regions so the light reflected by
the leaves lacks these two tones and we
see them as green color
anthocyanins absorb light from the blue
to the green so in this case the light
reflected by the leaves contains the
complementary colours which are red and
orange
all of that is to ask in what range of
the visible spectrum
do the carotenes absorb the most
what they've told us about the carotenes
is that those leaves are yellow orange
in colour
so if we look at the little colour wheel
we've got yellow and orange here
the complementary colors to those are
violet and blue
so those are the correct answer a
while these questions may not be as
rigorous as some of the other ones we've
seen
you still need a very broad base of
knowledge because you're doing
everything from writing essays to
answering these questions about the
planets
you might even learn a thing or two
while you're in the exam here's question
135 it tells us about the mimetic
octopus which has very curious color
patterns and behaviors it often changes
the orientation of its tentacles
resembling some other animals
here you can see the octopus mimicking
allura fish that's what a lure fish
looks like here it is mimicking a
lionfish and here it is mimicking a sea
snake the question asks from an
evolutionary point of view the capacity
presented was established because
octopuses what with the correct answer
being because they survived the
selective pressures with these behaviors
here's the start of the math section
again very wordy even for math questions
the amount of reading that's involved
means the test can become very tiring to
take especially after five hours of this
here's a question that jumps out as
being interesting it looks like a
tesseract a four-dimensional cube
the question says many toys that are
often found in public squares and parks
are shaped like two and
three-dimensional geometric figures a
company was hired to develop a new form
of toy the proposal presented by the
company was a structure formed only by
metal rods connected to each other as
shown in the figure but it turns out you
don't actually need to know anything
about four dimensional cubes because the
question just asks based on the proposal
presented how many plain geometric
figures of each type are formed by the
union of the rods so basically take a
good look at this picture and see how
many shapes are in there luckily the
first answer turns out to be the correct
one see if you can spot 12 isosceles
trapezoids and 12 squares here we have
the cutest little mug i've ever seen in
an exam with the question asking us to
find the volume of the shape here
now this is actually called a truncated
cone or a frustum and there is a formula
for finding the volume of one of these
so if you show up with that memorized
it's probably going to be a bit easier
for you but if you're left high and dry
and don't know the formula it's not
impossible to work it out from scratch
as well what you do is you imagine
extending this to become a
complete cone
and then you find the volume of this
large cone and subtract off the volume
of this little cone here doing that and
using 3 as an approximation for pi
you'll get 732 as the answer
they have this very intricate and very
brazilian question here about all of the
football teams the question had been
asking something about how many
combinations you could make if you
arranged all of these team logos on a
shelf with a set of intricate conditions
but in the end this question was
nullified because i think they couldn't
totally agree on what the correct answer
would be so all this work kind of was
for nothing
the second to last question 179 looks
best formatted in the portuguese version
and it's about the golden ratio it talks
about how if you have a line divided
into two parts then those two parts will
be in golden proportion
when the ratio between the whole and the
largest one of the parts is the same as
the ratio between the larger part and
the smaller part you can also find the
golden ratio as the solution to the
equation phi squared is equal to 5 plus
1
and that becomes the first element of
this table here it then goes on to say
that phi cubed can be found as 2 phi
plus 1 and there are similar relations
for the rest of the powers the question
is to find what would phi to the 7 be
equal to
i guess you don't need to understand the
context too much but if you just look at
the table and try to find a pattern that
will give you this missing box you might
notice the fibonacci numbers that the
coefficient out here in front of the phi
is the previous two added together 5
plus 3 gives you
two plus three gives you five one plus
two gives you three so with that we'd
have eight plus five is thirteen and the
fibonacci numbers are also in the second
term
one one two three five eight the golden
ratio and the fibonacci numbers are
interlinked with each other in so many
weird ways but if you didn't already
know that then good luck noticing it for
yourself during the pressure of the exam
the very last question is basically an
essay that describes this sculpture here
in brussels called the atomium
it tries to describe that the whole
thing is a giant cube tilted onto one
vertex which is touching the ground and
you can take an elevator straight up
from the sphere through the middle one
through to one at the top i found this
really hard to visualize given that you
can't really see half of it in this
picture here but the question says that
we have a visitor who moves around the
interior of the sculpture always
following the shortest path between
vertices and passing all edges and all
diagonals of the cube
they want to know what the path of this
traveler would look like if it was
projected down onto the ground the
question does say that there are nine of
these metal spheres
and since you're traveling to each one
of them you would expect i guess nine
distinct points on the projection
although this first part of the journey
up the elevator from the ground to the
middle to the top all three of those
spheres are in the same line so it would
only appear as one in total then we
would expect seven dots on the
projection
one two three four five six seven means
that e is the correct answer here it's
also got the right amount of symmetry
compared to c which would be more of a
rectangular sculpture i happen to have
seen a bit of a brazilian tv show called
three percent and it's this futuristic
dystopia where most people live in this
impoverished inland
and when everyone is 20 years old they
get a single opportunity to complete
something called the process which is
essentially a big test and only three
percent of candidates pass this test and
get to go and live luxurious affluent
lives in this distant offshore society
in the show passing the process is
basically your only chance at a good
life and so people spend their entire
lives up until they're 20 preparing for
this one shot
it's a fictional story that speaks to a
lot more social issues like inequality
but i can't help but notice a lot of
parallels between that show and this
exam
it's this idea that you spend so much of
your life preparing for one single test
which can determine so much of your
future
this article i found from inside higher
ed spoke about how in 2016 there were 8
million students who were competing for
approximately 250 000 places in the
federal universities and when you crunch
the numbers on this it works out to
around three percent the same number
that make it through in the show
in both cases whether you're talking
about the physical process that they go
through on tv
or this intellectual exam both are
supposed to give an equal chance to
everyone they're supposed to admit the
three percent most deserving candidates
but of course there's always issues
associated with that goal for one in
education private coaching and access to
better schools and teachers will always
be easier for people that start off from
a more privileged position but for many
countries not just brazil where you've
got huge numbers of students applying
for relatively small amount of places
then you need to figure out some way of
doing things and these giant exams seem
to be currently one of the best
strategies that we have i suppose as a
student you just have to do the best you
can to be prepared
and to not be late
i'd like to thank brilliant for
sponsoring this video if you're looking
for a last minute gift idea that doesn't
require postage then gifting someone a
brilliant membership may help them to
discover an interest in science and math
brilliant is an interactive stem
learning platform that helps you to
learn concepts by working through them
in visual hands-on ways
these are some clips from their recently
updated logic course that develops a
basis for mathematical reasoning
you use limited information to make
predictions and to uncover the truth
if you use my link which is
brilliant.org slash tibi's then you can
get 20 off an annual subscription and
this also applies for gifted memberships
so i hope that whoever receives it
enjoys learning something new
a big thank you to brilliant and thank
you to my patreon supporters for making
this video possible
a special shout out to today's rather
dog looking patron cat of the day peppa
[Music]